joining us now Missouri Senator Josh
Holly Senator as we're covering this
standoff at the border where the federal
government is trying to stop Texas from
doing just basic things to protect its
state sovereignty that's happening yet
Republicans are
grousing uh about populace and president
Trump saying no deal that you can't
trust these people what the heck is
going on
here yeah as always it's opposite stay
in in Washington Laura I mean the truth
is is the Biden Administration is 100%
responsible for what's going on at the
border and here's why the law hasn't
changed since Donald Trump was President
the only thing that's changed is Joe
Biden he wants the Border open that's
why it's open he wants the drugs pouring
across that's why they're coming into my
state and every state across this
country the human trafficking the human
smuggling the crime all of it is because
of Biden's policies and why Republicans
would ever bail him out and give him
more money to keep up these terrible
policies why they would ever help him
open the Border further or approve
50,000 more green cards every year is
beyond me I can tell you I will not vote
for any of that well your reaction to
Romney uh Kramer uh Senator Kramer um
senator from Indiana whose name I always
forget Todd young That's how little I
see him Todd young uh and others
Langford saying you know wait a second a
pres one person shouldn't subtle this
great bipartisan agreement uh that
that's just a tragedy we're really going
to fix the border and Trump's trying to
stop
us you know this isn't about uh Donald
Trump this is about the security of the
American people and I think let's not
blame Trump for doing something that all
of the American people are saying which
is secure the Border I mean you look at
by the way nobody has seen this deal
we're told it's like the best deal ever
it's wonderful you should all support it
they won't let us see it if it's so
wonderful
let's it but I tell you what I do about
it Laura is sounds it's going to ,000
more cards a year it sounds like
expedited work permits for illegal
aliens already in the country it sounds
like the border is not going to be
closed at all that's not a deal that's a
giveaway to Joe Biden why would anybody
in their right mind Republican Democrat
independent ever support that the
American people don't support it that's
the bottom line they're suing Texas for
actually enforcing the Border but then
Romney's like booh hooing because Donald
Trump's trying to prevent our great deal
they're not obviously going to enforce
the Border Senator I mean you don't have
to work at Bane Capital to know that
this is kind of basic you know logic and
Common Sense by the way uh Schumer has a
message for
Republicans Senate Democrats are going
to stay the course stay the course until
the job is done President Biden on
numerous occasions has stated he's
willing to work with Republicans in a
big way on immigration and over the past
and for over two months months Democrats
have shown we are serious about reaching
an agreement by remaining at the
negotiating table a complete fraud
Senator your response to that it's the
best comedy I've heard in some
time the only thing that uh Joe Biden
and the Democrats are serious about is
enabling the largest mass migration in
American history the largest number of
illegal border crossings ever in the
history of America listen I've sat
across from the DHS secretary Alejandra
mayorcas who's in charge of the border
and he has told me under oath and go
look it up that their policies are
working he says the Biden policies are
working that's the problem they are
working they want the Border open
borders they want this chaos open
borders this is what they want and this
is why Republicans need to say no
Senator is this deal dead
effectively uh I hope so it should be if
it's not dead yet it should be dead I
mean there is absolutely no reason to
agree to policies that will just further
enable Joe Biden Joe Biden needs to
close the border now he's got the
authority to do it just enforce the law
I mean it's that simple just enforce the
law that should be the bottom line
Senator thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else